we die young this is a movie that you've
made where your character is pretty much
what happened oh you're just prepared to
give coffee I know but you do way you
just went huh everything you do is like
junk I lie down I must have coffee you
just tore my crotch
in this film we die young your job is to
protect a ten-year-old from a street
gang and that's the role you're playing
and your character does not speak so you
had to do a lot of acting with your face
with your eyes right not really it's
like because people think it's like an
action movie and we have 20% action at
the end and it's about the ms-13 in
Washington DC the gang but it's a great
movie it's gonna open only on few
theaters and just look at the film it's
it's a different type of movie and the
actors are even better than me I'm not
bad I mean we have a clip we have a clip
let's take a look at this scene from we
die young you gotta show optionally
[Applause]
in a fight man in a fight between a car
and a motorcycle always pick the car